[Music]
so a lot of people in our audience use
Craigslist and it's just a fact a lot of
young people here a lot of them use
Craigslist so I thought we'd help our
audience members make a sale or
connection by showing some of their
craigslist ads right here on the show
[Applause]
first up for sale security footage of me
getting tasered on Reese Witherspoon's
porch one fit hot guys on the DL no not
on the down-low I have a fetish for
injured baseball player tired of not
being punched in the face then let me
punch you in the face
for sale new app that inserts my bare
ass into any family want it two tickets
to Woodstock what it happened already
higher casual wizard let's hang out some
spells or whatever
[Applause]
join me for a night of passionate
whittling bring a branch leave with a
walking stick $100 per hour one pig
hurry
we'll pay top dollar for a werewolf
antidote and finally free saxophone
lessons you must provide saxophone
instructor student and two saxophones
[Music]
[Applause]
now God